ist ja jetzt wechseln wir von krähen
amitec auf waro drei pack das offizielle
pack wie gesagt und zwar genau jetzt los
gehts und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video in dem ich euch heute mal
etwas vorstellen darf was euch sicher
interessieren und zwar gibt es heute für
euch das war o3 texture pack ich werde
euch das heute kurz mal zeigen und ein
bisschen kommentieren so im detail was
ist alles drin wie sieht's aus was
bringt was kann was kann es nicht wie
viel ist der sinn des lebens schreiben
manche 42 ohne aber nie ganz im ernst
ich wollte mal wissen präsentieren was
es sich mit dem vario texture pack auf
sich hat einzig reich dankeschön für all
das werde wie viel zeit ich habe holla
die vilser junge das ist eine menge
eine menge holz oder vorne ist aber auch
noch einer nicht mehr will ich jetzt
nicht so gerne ein kissen lassen sich
sagen vielleicht kann man hier holen was
sagst du kann man nicht holen kann man
nicht holen
wie ist der stand bei der liga ich
glaube auch oder ich kann mir schon
holen meinte nicht ja alles egal kommen
ja es gibt ja ein vorgeschriebenes
texture pack und war das habe ich auch
schon mal in videos und streams
angedeutet aber es war bisher noch nicht
klar wie dieses texture pack aussieht
heute ist es öffentlich in einer
vorläufigen fassung ist es noch nicht
ganz endgültig
ja okay wir machen mit einem hit drei
herzen gezogen vier herzen
ok seltsamer typ ich weiß nicht ich mein
gott schafft verzaubern ich las es
erstmalig laufen über eine runde so ich
drehe jetzt einfach mal ne runde wenn
ich einen ruhigen punkt finde dann zeige
ich euch einfach mal das war op kompakt
ist einfach mal rein
hier live noch haben wir das kran am
apec darin dass 1.8 das dürfte die ja
mittlerweile schon kennen zunächst ihr
kennt ihr das
warum ist da ja da ist einer so also das
hier ist noch heute könnte man den
vergleich bisschen sehen so war opec zu
kran am gepäck gerne mal dann auch in
die kommentare schreiben
was euch besser gefällt davon so der
krieg auf jeweils gut schaden
denen habe ich ihn kurz aus den augen
verloren hat nämlich fast noch geholt
oder zwei herzen
so jetzt ist aber der ruhige punkt
eingetreten wenn man erreicht es ist
eingetreten
wer sich in ruhigen zeitpunkt zu dem von
ihm gesprochen habe das pack wechseln
bzw
wir holen uns erstmal den ja noch oder
du weißt nicht wie wenige herzen hier
und so ziemlich direkt eingreifen eine
gute sache dass du es nicht wahrnimmst
barbapapa dada red okay doch zumindest
man nicht direkt in das tnt rades machen
sonst die meisten aber er hat auch nicht
so die box rüstung hat und die box waffe
ich glaube ich die die objekte die man
ein bisschen mehr schaden vielleicht
nutzt jetzt einfach diesen job und um zu
wechseln okay also klar alles klar jetzt
wechseln wir von krähen amitec auf war
o3 pack dass das offizielle pack wie
gesagt und zwar genau jetzt sagt hier
ist es ihr seht schon war o 350 32 mal
also es ist ein 32 gepäck das heißt
relativ geringe auflösung und dazu ist
es auf facebook basis also ein mac mit
dem ich bisher noch gar keinen kontakt
hatte das heißt ich muss mich erstmal
eingewöhnen
und ferner ist ein full glaube ich
solche spec ist relativ nah an der
vanilla edition dran ist manchmal so
anschaut ganz doofe ecke hier so mache
ich nicht rein laufen bekommt man
nämlich nicht wieder raus aber glück
gehabt hier relativ nah an vanilla dran
vom block gewannen damit wenn man nicht
die fort aber es ist an sich eigentlich
ein ganz schick aspect obwohl es sehr
sympathisch ist mag ich es eigentlich
ganz gern
wo ist denn jetzt geht es doch einer
drin wo ist da als einer der männer die
axt okay er läuft ja irgendwie ist weg
wir haben jetzt den hier
der brand hat den eisen fertig kannst
ganz schlecht erkennen nee nee nee jetzt
kommt der anderen und shops so dreist ab
alter schwede nicht dein ernst läuft
erst noch weg von mir und dann
abgestorben junge junge junge junge
junge junge das ist echter nummer jetzt
mir hinterher egal läuft alles ich hab
mir selbst auch manchmal ab das hat nur
richtig ärgerlich in der aufnahme weil
die hatte glaubte alter ok gönnt ihr
könnt ihr ruhig die von allen rüstung
durchgekämpft hat gern ihres eisen
schwert ist auf jeden fall cool von dir
und jetzt müssen wir gucken dass wir den
rasieren ort danke dass ihr da
vornehmlich auf mich gegangen ist hat
nämlich richtig besser getestet hallo
liebe drin im team oder wahrlich nicht
angegriffen
der ist der zweck der iss kaputt
gegangen alles klar
so hatte das top stars of staff leider
keine feste ich nicht nein
verbrennt läuft weiter hinterher
foto steht das war ganz schlecht das war
ganz schlecht muss ich durchziehen
bitte lassen kann hier danke schön danke
danke danke weil das schwer das war ganz
schlecht ganz ganz dumm gelaufen
cambrai nochmal burn baby burn werden
doch einfach mal für mich fangen an zu
brennen
ich bin nicht so der hype hat super
super placement typ der irgendwie einmal
feuer fertig minister gegner weg komplex
erst so dass aufpassen dass patti
willhardt auch als die habe ich aber
glaube ich schon
zack zack zack zack das war alles nicht
sehr gut durchs rüstung scale-up step
haben den bogen ja sieben fälle auch
eine gute sache wie viele user finden es
dir noch sechs benutze ich lieber mann
nicht um die eltern zu verbrennen alte
wir können natürlich entscheidenden ich
hänge die ganze zeit sich auf gar nichts
wir können noch mal ganz relax & easy
entscheid dankeschön ich wollte die ein
steak essen yo-yo ma drüber erstmal kein
gegner in der nähe ok level 1 endstand
und power natürlich dann würde ich sagen
entscheiden wir nochmal die leggins
protection sehr nice und vielleicht noch
ein spätes wir entscheiden können naja
faktor kommt eine davon nicht bieten
nicht so jung war direkt hinter mir
alter schwede junge nein er hat sich das
die welt geholt der rüdiger eltern
brennt jetzt bisschen gas geben kämpft
die erstmal ging
kempf was man gegen den hol dir den
polier den ich wüsste text vorstellen
also nochmal ein abschließendes urteil
ich finde das pack eigentlich ganz nice
es ist sehr sehr simpel klar so kann
niemand macht ihr mit dem schwert alte
deathmatch regel kaum laufwerk ja
springen bisschen vor und zurück das
beeindruckt mich nicht so muss ich sagen
ich mache jetzt halt auch ein paar
bogener also er wird auch seine leben
verlieren ja geben auf den anderen auf
den andern kindern genau wie man schon
auf den beinen die wie gesagt niemand
macht mit dem schwert nicht kann einfach
ja dort mit feile diskussion nicht gegen
mich war nicht gegen wichtiger wäre cool
wäre cool dass der weg der war schick
jetzt soll auch gut von ihm er guckt man
legt ist voller einfach unter sich stark
aber dieser bringt hat auch nicht mehr
so viele leben ja ist es
nice nice junge richtig gut war opec
bringt mir glück gibt mir die djs und
jetzt könnt ihr nämlich nicht nur das
sondern auch mal hier
willste verschreibt der kula gut auf
jeden fall egal
gogo pilz an ich bin nicht so der große
anleger muss man sagen hat er 19 viele
schaffen es die erschwert protection
against sollte eingelaufen läuft nicht
schlecht
kriegt auch schon ein paar pfeile ja
okay dann macht es sogar noch mit dem
pfeil hinterher
er hatte hat er obwohl life habe ich den
so schnell runter gezockt auf jeden fall
was schöne runde leute schreibt bitte in
die kommentare was er von dem pack halt
mich interessieren und macht irgendwie
vorschläge wie das verändern kann ich
darf wie gesagt die welt verändern und
waffen darf ich verändern das sind die
einzigen sache
eure vorschläge gerne wenn ihr jemanden
wisst ihr sowas gut verändern kann
schreibt mir auch mal den namen die
kommentare
wir sehen zum nächsten video wieder
daumen stimme helfen